benjamin castaldi le cas d'annie les
deux n'ont point c'est la réalité vous
zappez 6 ou des amis à lui dire pourquoi
les marseillais le poème qui marche le
mieux il faut un effort de casting parce
que c'est ça se renouvelle
d'une saison à l'autre qui garde est
ancien il met de nouveau les autres ici
c'est le change on les voit à gauche on
les voit à droite ça tourne en rond
c'est la même chose et les gens ils
veulent voir des gens nouveaux et harry
foulée comme les puces secret story qui
a alimenté considérablement le réservoir
c'est vrai avec des allées dont il était
tombé 10 10 12 qu'on est à nouveau
parents le vrai foot maintenant les
boîtes de production 1
il ya plutôt eu de casting zaki prévoit
là il serait n'importe quoi et souvent
c'est n'importe quoi comme ici à pau
comme ici et surtout ne pleuvrait presse
et que on sent bien que les journées ce
qu'il faut répéter les phrases pour
expliquer ce qu'on vient de voir les
gens il connaît ça par coeur ils sont
sous les extraits - le cache de lire
dans les marseillais voilà ce qu'on aime
aussi ces sont les clashs ça fait partie
des ingrédients pour que ça marche
enfin tout cas dans les marseillais
aussi de cesser l'émission c'est la
seule qui marque les bons risques et on
vous accomp à les compiler les plus gros
clash de télé réalité vous allez voir
parfois ça va hyper mendiants de terenez
écrite
culture a parlé
c'est l'été
non
ces morts et moi on ne me fais jamais ça
je le ferais pas ça mais fais pas ça
coûte voit bien ici t'es chez moi tu
fais en tant qu est ce qui t chez moi je
te gère mais tu l'as mont panié et une
laisse là où je te mets une droit
nantais dans ta plus dedans
ça fait six ans que reprocher en effet
les rails déçu de nombreux parents qui
nous regardent l'église
moi je veux pas que mes enfants
regardent pas ce qu'il ya trop de classe
il ya trop de choses comme ça vous vous
zappez pourquoi et parce que je suis sur
w9 c'est le groupe rtl c'est le groupe
m6 attention lorsque la faire tout seul
et il a là c'est peut-être fait une
connerie jacques les audiences de rtl
oui c'est vrai que vous alors oui pardon
est-ce que la fraîcheur a totalement
disparu et la preuve en est que lorsque
vous mettez vous effacer les logos vous
mettez toutes les photos des différents
candidats sur un mur et bien les neuf
dixièmes des gens maintenant on n'arrive
plus à les distinguer les uns des zones
donc même pour eux pour percer c'est de
moins en moins facile
donc ça veut dire que ça n'est plus
intéressant pour quasiment personne
commet pas fait pas tout compris c'est
aussi des ballons n'arrivent plus à vous
dire si c'est vrai et on aime rtl bercy
première à de france encore avec jameer
t elle en plus c'est vrai qu ils vous le
rendent bien
la direction soutient monsieur je les
aime beaucoup j'avoue et voilà mais
j'aime bien vous taquinez alors vous
jean michel mercier vous êtes fan oui
moi je suis fan des jalles j'ai
participé une fois j'ai eu la chance
d'aller à miami pour aller voir les ans
je suis resté qu'une journée mais j'aime
ça mais perd une voix le dessous des
décors c'était franchement très drôle ce
qui est moche comme des malades du matin
de 7 heures du matin jusqu'à minuit à
son sujet par des caméras sert sa bonne
humeur change de voir des gens sérieux
il ya des mecs qui bossent s'arrête
jamais ils le prennent comme ça
d'ailleurs il se tenir
il traîne jamais les pieds ils le font
vraiment avec enthousiasme trois ans
après ils sont plus pris et puis je
trouve c'est quand même choix est
difficile c'est toujours dans les
paysages sublimes et les beaux mecs des
belles nanas et puis ça permet de ne pas
lâcher l'armp aux vêtements pour
commence à vieillir
on voit encore les expressions les
rapports amoureux entre jeunes ça donne
quand même une idée de pas toute la
jeunesse une certaine jeunesse la façon
de se comporter mais